chez nous il ya aussi cure de comtois
que j'ai là avec une en exclu ce qui
explique voilà que c'est un peu léger et
bourgogne magazine et son père spirituel
qui était avec nos dominique bruillot
pour nous raconter des sagas de la
région et vous qui est éditeur depuis
1995 de toutes ces belles choses dites
moi qu'est ce que vous nous avez choisi
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi de nous raconter
les origines d'alstom tout ça tient donc
ok voilà donc on va découvrir java pour
commencer les ateliers peut-être de la
société lançons alsacienne voilà
allons-y commençons avec les ateliers de
la société alsacienne est mal à être
assuré m
c'était la sienne de construction
mécanique c'est pas simple à dire qui tu
es né de la fusion en 1872 de la fusion
de deux autres sociétés alors je vais
être horrible c'est à casser et
graffenstaden jeune fille avoir été la
recette c'est pas la peine qu'on va
arrêter là
mais surtout ce rapprochement et des
aînés au lendemain au lendemain de la
deûle de l'annexion de l'alsace et de la
lorraine pour permettre de concurrencer
les allemands et et à belfort c'est une
succursale spécialisée dans le montage
final des locomotives avec des pièces
produites en alsace on ne s'en rend pas
bien compte là mais il y avait plus de
500 emplois au début ça allait beaucoup
plus lent que ça en 1881 il y avait à
peu près 5 180 personnes
et ça ira encore beaucoup plus loin plus
tard puisque il ya une demande très
forte
on va voir dans les images suivantes là
justement on va on va voir un petit peu
les ateliers de l'intérieur si on arrive
à prendre une autre image jeune et
voyageait calmement alors voilà elle
vous montre où on vous montre aussi la
une de bourgogne magazine pour que vous
puissiez bien comprendre parce que c'est
un magazine qu'on retrouve un peu
partout comme corps de comtois très
bientôt
et là comme en étant
dans la franche comté avant d'arriver à
belfort de revenir à belfort on voulait
aussi vous explique tout ça prenne voilà
un gros plan intérieur
gros plan intérieur calme impressionnant
quand même sur une demande qui est forte
j'imaginais bah oui parce que on fait
tous ici on usines ont fait la
chaudronnerie on forge et puis en 1887
par exemple on produit pas moins de
quatre locomotives qui chaque mois
j'ai pas si vous imaginez des grosses
locomotives et tant et si bien que avec
les tensions avec l'allemagne le l'état
français objet de créer une société
différente et mais elle prend une
importance incroyable puisqu'elle
atteint 6700 ouvriers juste avant la
guerre et je peux dire que la première
locomotive à vapeur a été produite à
belfort 1881 pour être très précis
ouais on va voir un plan un peu plus
large
des ouvriers dans ce qui ressemble au
marché parce que là on sent que les
membres mais ça ressemble un peu à un
sous marin je trouve nabeul là je crois
qu'on est dans les moteurs le bateau
c'est possible que je sois cette photo
vu les habits a été prise un peu plus
tard mais en tout cas il faut savoir que
pendant la première guerre mondiale
l' usine à fabriquer plus de 5 millions
d'obus passe pour les oeufs pour
l'effort de guerre donc ce qui l'a
considérablement développé et après en
39 elle est devenue alstom alors alston
c'est encore une fois la réunion de la
société alsacienne de constructions
mécaniques et de la compagnie française
thomson houston le tome 2 axes comme
c'est thompson et tout d'un coup le lait
ça va changer puisque pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale le reste on va passer
sous la coupe allemande et produira pour
l'heure h
quand même une histoire quand même qui
va dans un sens et dans l'autre
mélusine reste toujours parce que
l'outil est un délocalisables et à
l'époque avait 6700 voyez quand c'était
juste avant un voyou et rouvre des
montées je crois plus que ça je n'ai pas
les chiffres exacts mais on est monté à
saint-louis mid on a beaucoup parlé de
locomotives à venir sur une locomotive
avec un gros plan sur la loco avec
vraiment alstom en gros le vois bien
alstom belfort langue alors comme vous
je suis un petit ac 1-1 tout à l'heure
vous nous avez piéger un bon jour c'est
pas mon genre en sicile à mon tour ça
n'est pas une locomotive qu'est ce que
c'est ça c'est le moteur d'un pack
et pas n'importe quel paquebot le
normandie ah oui le nord lens quoi et
oui oui oui alors et le normandie vous
connaissez son destin les parties voguer
sur d'autres cieux oui il est parti aux
états unis il était un réseau neigeux
parce que le terme est correcte par les
américains et en 42 un incendie a ravagé
pendant une période de travaux et ce
sont les pompiers qui ont enroulé en est
un à 110 ont enfin un peu fini le bateau
et le bateau était détruit en 46 que la
france voulait pas le récupérer allez on
va terminer on va terminer avec une
dernière image parce que moi quand je
pense à alstom des désolé mais je pense
que locomotive et locomotives
voilà du futur en fin de bail présent
celle là vous la verrez en 2024 puisque
c'est le tgv du futur voilà ça c'est en
service pour les jo qui sur lequel
belfort travail est alors j'aimerais
bien comme on qu'on rappelle les 30
secondes
voilà il faut les vivre comme le tgv 1
331 km heure en 55 et on est arrivés
très vite je grille les étapes un
hallucinant 55 115 kilomètres-heure
quelque temps après on là je pense qu'on
a un peu arrêté la course à la vitesse
on est plutôt dans des logiques
aujourd'hui de confort et de bien-être
avec ses tgv aux allures de plus en plus
il ya quand même hallucinant 515 km race
et leur corps où elle a commencé à gérer
voila voila on les a doublées sur france
télé vous avez servi à beaucoup de
choses c'est qu'on en sait plus sur
notre jura et sur alstom m6 était rapide
comme le tgv je rappelle coeur de
comtois 1 ça c'est la une qui va sortir
le bourgogne magazine dont on reparlera
évidemment régulièrement notre grande
région franche-comté super